now if you're going to have consent
that's a very radical thing to think
the king of england didn't think that
what is consent
and why it's kind of more or less a
social contract
that both parties are agreeing to the
terms and conditions
we as the people being governed are
allowing those
who are in power to look over and
provide the necessary securities so we
can
as they put to pursue our happiness we
might stick with just something direct
and simple and
understandable right like if we're equal
you wouldn't have the authority to do
something to me
unless i say so whereas
the king answered the declaration of
independence did you know that
he gave an address from the throne and
he gave an answer
and he basically said in there i was
born to be the king here
and you were born to be the subjects and
i am required to look after you and be
good to you and take care of you and to
do what's in your interest
what's good for you but you are required
to do what i say
and he thought that that would turn the
whole thing around
and at the moment that he distributed
this thing across the lines
to the continental army
it was melting away because their their
enlistments were up
and they read that thing and they went
what
is that what he thinks we're gonna we're
staying
we're gonna do this thing right the
king's idea
is that i was born with an obligation
and you were born with an obligation we
both have to do our thing
and we're born that way and the
declaration of penis denies that
it says we're all born equal
so that's what they say and if it's like
that
then you get to be our king
if we say so there's a really great
document that we're not reading in this
course but i encourage everyone to read
it in our constitution reader
is written by thomas jefferson who of
course was a very powerful writer
earth-shakingly powerful writer wrote
the declaration of independence
and it's called a summary view of the
rights of british north america
and in there he goes on and on and on
and he explains
you get to be the king if we say so
you have to do what we say in the last
paragraph which i'll paraphrase
he says that let those flatter
who fear it is not an american
art your counselors
are partisans not drawn from us
right so he's telling the king
what for you know and it gives rise soon
you know the flag with the snake
that says don't tread on me
we have a right we are born the same as
you
you get your carriage since you got it
all ready
it's just that you don't get to tell us
what to do from it
consent is born inequality in that way
right and and just you just have to
remember
that we americans we just breathe
that from birth we get that with
mother's milk
you know that's what we think we think
we're born equal it's the reason why
we think we can do whatever we want
if we work hard enough it's the reason i
thought
you know i grew up my dad's a
schoolteacher from pocahontas arkansas
right
but i didn't know that that wasn't the
grandest thing in the world to be
i knew we weren't rich but i didn't
think anybody was born better than i
nor i better than anybody else uh
churchill i
used to love to say about equality he'd
say
it's the principle that everybody is as
good as everybody else
or a little better
would you like that church it was very
witty so
so now if you're going to have consent
that's a very radical thing to think
the king of england didn't think that
right the fact that he gave that address
from the throne
and had it distributed he thought that
would be persuasive
right later they send ben franklin
who was let's call it let's say
a very artful human being we all know
what that means right
for example he was the world's greatest
spokesman for
for uh pius middle-class morality
anyway they sent him to england to
negotiate he didn't get on one they
liked him better in paris
he went there too and he gets over there
and he talks with the cabinet
and the cabinet says we are the mother
country
and you are the children and you must do
what we say
and he writes a letter back to the to
the continental congress and says
there's going to be a war because
what they think is and and remember
what they think is what everybody thinks
it's what the king of france thinks who
later subsidized our revolution it's
what they all think it's what the world
has thought
from time immemorial and these guys
don't think that
that's a remarkable development in human
history
thank you for watching we hope you're
enjoying our highlight series and invite
you to explore
all of hillsdale college's online
courses they are free
and for everyone who loves to learn